have you ever slept with a black guy no
but i really want to thank you
i told myself this morning i wasn't
gonna fall in love don't hold me back
doc don't hold me back hello sir i would
like a
rummy coke okay
that's okay we've got beers
oh man do not get me started on the
mexicans hey
i'll just say it
they hold the goddamn economy together
you know what man damn straight if 12 of
the mexicans lived in this country
stopped working just 12 percent
the usa would shut down i don't even
care who hears me no they they they they
work their asses off mm-hmm and they got
strong family values essential
immigrants
hey speaking of immigrants
how about damn asians
you know what brother you want a lot
that fuse and you better stand back
cause i got something i want to say
about those mother
i got three words for you
estudious hard-working industrious damn
straight asians are
the highest income best educated and the
fastest growing racial group in the usa
um plus
got the highest percentage of college
graduates in the country good for them
and maybe this makes me sound racist but
those mothers
they're gonna save the country
there it is you went and said it i just
said i just came right out and said it
was in everyone's mind but i'm the one
who said it hey and you know what while
we're at it i'm gonna break my spine tip
tap dancing winston prancing around the
elephant in the room yep blacks
blacks
[ __ ] blacks you know what you done
done did you open up the floodgates now
my friend release the kraken goddamn
victims uh institutionalized racism
[Applause]
they overcame the slavery and the
segregation just to become ceos
and entrepreneurs hey one of them's the
god starring president and i mean that's
just true right there that's this
historical fact man can't even argue
that
oh how about the indians
in native
americans i don't know if i could get in
trouble
these days for saying something like
this but they were here first it may be
unpopular but it's true we came to this
country and we steamrolled on in and we
genocided them i mean hell we owe them
something there you go
[Music]
i gotta tell you man that's not bad for
a nine alcoholic beer not bad at all all
right i gotta go home take care of my
kids how many of them you got now just
adopted the 11th nope can't help myself
man that's always what happens when you
volunteer for the earthquake relief in
haiti
and what you going to do
you know my wife makes two-thirds of
what i make what y'all got the same job
man that's just patently unfair that's
right we're both librarians nurbs you
all right i'm okay but i just finished
episode four okay so the lannisters
[Music]
and the female lannister is married to
robert uh of baranthian who is the king
it's is it baranthian or baratheon right
right and then the other blonde girl
is the um
can i get you something oh oh i don't
know um three kamikaze shots whatever
[Music]
i can't believe he just did that what's
that
it served me before you guys i'm really
against that i'm so sorry
nah it's okay we uh we've got beers no i
mean i'm sorry about
everything well it's fine no no it's
been a hundred years of not fine i mean
20 years ago you guys wouldn't have even
been allowed in here 20 years that would
be 1992.
it was really beautiful
oh she's done that just happened didn't
it
yeah oh amazing
so okay with the lannisters okay the
she's the queen jamie lannister is the
other one jamie yo yo what up man hey
give me another lager what i mean da
spilled my last one i'm a tribe shirt
you believe that
but whatevs got this thing in 93.
midnight marauders tour check that out
it's everywhere oh man hey uh who's your
favorite member of
tribe smoke smoke smokey
no man
love him dude he's going behind the
scenes but he was like
all right good see you guys around
though mm-hmm cool okay one more one
more one more come on sign boom
all right wait oh he spun wow he spun
second person to not wait for their
drink by the way yep
okay let me ask you this thing um what
what's what's with the barbarian dude
who looks like a huge dave navarro
i need a drink
just finished amistad i saw it three
times and i'll see you a hundred more
times because like i'm happy to do it if
that's what those guys went through i'm
happy to sit through it you know 300
more times or whatever you know it takes
yeah it's it's a it's pretty intense i
think my thing is it's like i don't
think one person should own another
person
period i'm glad that that's what you got
from me
yeah i mean i don't care when it
happened all right it should never
happen it should never occur but like
i'm preaching to the choir you guys know
what i'm talking about yeah i'm like
it's like why did anybody even do that
i'm like no you didn't no you didn't
what you doing girl man now you did
i'm ashamed you know what it's it's
really probably okay because you weren't
there okay well we can come up with
excuses all day all day
excuse me let's just not do that let's
let's not look hey bottom line mm-hmm we
cool
right yeah all right yeah we are cool
we're kicking a cow yes
what's that nothing how you didn't
all right four more years
hey if it makes you guys feel any better
black people make me really
uncomfortable
[Music]
thank you
oh man i really had to get out of the
house i'm just glad you came out i
appreciate it for real
i'm gonna go check this girl out man she
is fine
she i
relay amen i am going to go to the
bathroom okay man
you know what i told myself this morning
i wasn't gonna fall in love
you went and made me break my only rule
i'm gonna take that right quick i am
going to take that i'm going to use that
okay
oh hey what's up man
got her number huh yeah cheyenne oh was
that her name yeah she would fly that's
that's the girl i was talking about
oh snap are you serious yeah dude oh i'm
sorry ain't no thing but forget it
there's plenty of items
i'm not a sports man but
i think me and you could touch down
later if you know what i'm saying
am i being stupid but for real though
just give me your number whatever
thank you girl i'm gonna take that from
you
how did you get over here so fast
huh
nothing it just seemed like you
the death toll has climbed to seven damn
second day that reporter is smoking hot
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
no
no
oh
[Music]
no
no hey baby
how are you
how are you doing honey what's wrong
baby i love you
i'm sorry i was out i was looking at
other women tonight
but you are all there is
i love you
nasty girls
[Music]
hey what
what what what can i get you hello sir i
would like a
ramen coke
coming up
[Music]
hey
where you from
[Music]
oh all right baby
i'm gonna see on the dance floor girl
oh
ah
it's rum and coke give me eight dollars
eight dollars all right my good man
all right okay all right
[Music]
yeah just take the card out keep that
open for me can you hang on to the vomit
will do
in fact let me get a tequila shot
brother
actually make it two man one for me and
one for you my good man
two tequila shots coming right up how
you doing here
all right nectar of the guys up in here
all right all right let's get that going
all right cheers
you want some help with that hold up let
me just try to get up in
[Applause]
my here you know what what ah i'm gonna
get you one of these yeah try that
anyway all right hey you're a genius let
me get this going on here
i just
so uh i'm worried about you oh now i'm
gonna tell you what i'm worried about
i'm worried that this club ain't popping
up the way it should be what what
cause i wait a second
what uh oh
dj turn it up that's my trap right there
[Music]
hey man a bar is not the place for you
to be right now
[Music]
let me get two more shots of tequila
sorry pal you're 86. what how what now
and what that's let's go
[Music]
doing
buddy
first time i think
it's like 87
as a two guys heavyweight pout
yeah
no it was the first time in a
heavyweight bout that the uh the two
fighters ended up getting married
hello my good sir
i like to have two shots out the king
[Music]
i want to know what's going on with the
huge woman and i want to know what the
deal is with the red witch lady
yes
yes you know what i'm saying just
straighten it out but i mean like have
you have you have you ever slept with a
black guy no but i really want to me too
apparently it is like a whole other
thing than sleeping with white men oh no
no i i heard they're supposed to be like
way better at it or something yeah yeah
yeah you heard that too
i wonder if it's because they have like
like better rhythm
you know
right because they're really good
dancers i mean apparently they have like
bigger
oh way bigger penises right
i guess that's because of africa
yeah like i feel like they're just
they're like really with you in the
moment like if they're gonna be with you
they're in the here and now exactly
exactly
because they know that they basically
have no future think about it so sad
think about it
i do feel like they treat their women
with just like a little bit more
compassion yeah look respect and stuff
oh
because their dads were never around oh
right
and they also have a lot of time on
their hands because even if they have
kids they never go visit them oh please
totally baby daddy that's a thing oh
that's in the dictionary now because of
black people see
seriously
apparently black guys just know how to
please white women right just like way
more than white men oh well it's
probably in their blood
because they're used to pleasing their
white masters
yeah law of the jungle right totally i
am so desperate to find out for myself
me too all right
okay
um
i'm gonna go to the bathroom okay
and i swear to you if there's a black
guy back there i'm gonna blow it
get it
so unrelated i
now have to go to the bathroom uh
because i've been drinking coffee all
day
so
i will be back in a little while well
you know what let me go first i'll be
about 30 seconds
ooh ow i hit my penis there
i'm sorry i don't have any money sir
okay
i said i said it right there i was like
it's like i was like you a woman
i'm a man that's a different oh what
they bumping up in here here it is it's
going off yo
which one are your mother
[ __ ]
me i did
my friends holding me you lucky cause
i'll take your head off don't hold me
back dog don't hold me back oh okay and
don't worry
see
i know though
if i were to lunge at you right now my
friend right here he catch me at the
last possible second no no no i won't
but my friend does have the cognizance
to tell me i don't need to be going up
and committing capital murder up in a
club tonight just knock him unconscious
dog bam
[Music]
i'm gonna kill anybody
no need for that success
tear them up
i will but
let me finish my sentence sir
i will
oh snap you know what
you lucky my boy's using his telekinetic
powers to hold me back right now no i'm
not
well maybe
it's the type of telekinesis that's a
mutant power that you didn't realize you
had until the moment
it started
oh i got it i see i see it so you want
me to hold
i'm a lion i'm a tiger over here i'm a
bear oh my oh i go crazy on you oh i
can't believe it he's like he's like a
tornado i mean don't hold me back i
can't even believe i can hold him back i
can't even do it man believe i'm this
strong let me go look at this i'm one
arm and i can't believe i'm this strong
let me just look at this man i'm gonna
hold it one finger like a little baby he
can't get past me he's like a little out
what you i'm a little baby i'm holding
you back man stupid man i got carried
away i apologize which mean you got
carried away you told me hold you back i
was holding your back what do you want
me to do in a fight situation new means
no and yes means yes how would i have
known that so well
what come on man ow come on that hurt
and you holding me back now thank you
very much for that okay we'll just at
least change it up
okay now you listen
oh hold on a second
oh
hell no he did not just text me he
working late
it's weak
you know what working late my ass if you
don't walk through that door in the next
half an hour he misses when i can come
home tonight cause i'm not gonna be
there waiting for his cheating ass okay
hey you know what i'm saying i will be
there waiting because
but he gonna have to put up with a lot
of from me okay and if he then he gonna
do this again he is sorely mistaken all
kind of because my man gets one chance
one okay and then after that he get one
more okay and then after that he gonna
get three strikes
okay if i ever find out that my man
was messing around on me he better get
as far away from me as he possibly can
because he do not want to get what i'm
gonna give to him okay i got my mother
real estate license okay
but if and when he does come home that's
fine okay cause he can go out and get
all turnt up with these little side hoes
and whatnot cause you know what [ __ ] he
always gonna come home all right okay
i'm the queen bee and he always gonna
come home to me you know what okay
i don't even care
oh okay but i'll tell you what happened
if you do come home okay you ain't gonna
be pulling
if he wants to but he ain't never gonna
do that when i'm home all right you know
what even if i'm home
it's fine
you know what i'm talking about okay
cause i don't give a good goddamn okay
that's what i'm talking about but he
ain't gonna bring that into my bedroom
i'll tell you that much right now okay
because they know try finesse they're
gonna wake me up while he's cheating on
me in my bed again okay
and i told him i looked it right in the
face i said this is the fifth and last
time
[Music]
i couldn't have said it better myself
though you're right
okay
you just been spouting words of wisdom
all evening i ain't listening to a
damn thing you saying
i don't even know what the hell i was
thinking girl you're right
the second that that man walks through
that door i'm gonna dump his hands oh
okay okay okay oh my gosh speak of the
devil
[Music]
oh
okay
okay
[Music]